joe biden is running out of options
he can't keep hiding from the american
people that hurts his poll numbers
but he can't keep talking either because
that also hurts his poll numbers he can
no longer talk about afghanistan
immigration the economy
abortion election integrity or even the
coronavirus which used to help his poll
numbers but now like all those other
issues hurts them
so the only thing he's got
to help boost his popularity
is to stoke fears of the sun monster
for decades
scientists have warned of extreme
weather
would be more extreme and climate change
was here and we're living through it now
we don't have any more time
i hope no one
i've been on the
telephone or on the road
an awful lot
between
california
idaho
new orleans excuse not new orleans
louisiana but new orleans mississippi
and you know here i mean every part of
the country
every part of the country is getting hit
by extreme weather
and uh we're now living in real time
what the country is going to look like
now wait a second
if climate change is already here
and we're out of time and there's no way
to prevent it
then i guess there's no point talking
about it
so so even climate change that old
democrat boogeyman
even that
doesn't look like it can save joe biden
because because it's too late it's over
joe biden cannot even fear monger on the
sun monster correctly the the way you
fearmonger on the sun monster is you you
always say
that the devastating effects are just a
little bit into the future and we can
still prevent them but time's running
out they've been saying this since the
1970s and they've changed the specifics
about what's going to happen so
initially it was going to be an ice age
and it was global cooling and but
there's still a little bit of time but
time is running out and then it became
global warming and it's going to get
really really hot and but time is
running out and then it became climate
change which was unfalsifiable and it
was it's going to happen in 12 years 10
years prince charles said it was going
to happen in 18 months he said that
several years ago so i guess we're
already past the point of no return
according to to prince charles aoc is a
little bit smarter than the future king
of england uh she she put it a little
bit further into the future so i think
we're still what eight or nine years
away from the aoc apocalypse but joe
biden he can't even do it right he puts
it in the past he says we're already out
of time well if we're already out of
time then who cares buster
well
joe biden cannot even name
the sorts of extreme weather that he's
fearmongering about
you know the
looks like a tornado they don't call
them that anymore
that hit the crops and and wetlands in
the middle of the country and
in iowa and nevada and i mean it's just
across the board
now listen i know that political
correctness is getting extreme i know
that we're changing all of the words i
just wrote a book on it but we can't
we can't call tornadoes tornadoes
anymore what what do we have to call
them
some have suggested it's it'll be like
torn tornadex
you know like they did with latino at le
tin
you just take away all of the vowels and
then you've got but i don't know what
what is he thinking of he's not thinking
of very much is the problem with him
so the climate change thing is not going
to work
afghanistan obviously that's a terrible
issue for the democrats all of these
issues are really not working one other
area where they're trying to fear monger
a little bit
is abortion they're really focusing in
on texas
which they have acknowledged to be the
sacrament
of liberalism that's why they're teaming
up with the satanic temple in texas
i'm so glad you enjoyed that show that
makes me feel good please leave me a
comment if you want to say hey michael i
like that show that was fun you can
catch the whole episode here at youtube
or what i would recommend
take out your phone go to the podcast
app apple podcast spotify google play
stitch or wherever you go
type in the michael knowles show
you type that in i guess you're probably
using your thumbs you type that in it
might not even come up at the top
sometimes they like to
push this down a little bit even though
it's it's the michael knowles it's big
show you know subscribe leave a five
star review
i really appreciate it we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]